we live in the world of blurring
boundaries between sectors of Industry
between known countries and territories
everything is changing the one global
challenge that most people around the
world are most worried about these days
namely climate change require new
committed and global problem solving
alliances countries are slowly becoming
outdated they need to realize that the
borders are partial and their people and
their governments are one in the same
free education a universal education and
free and universal health care people
need to start coming together start
coming together as a global community
everyone together improving everyone
else's quality of life and that's what
should be done together as a global
community we have the resources we have
the intention we have the skills we have
the knowledge and we have the funds to
transform Africa to uplift the orphans
and to heal the sick I would look at
world going forward where everyone has
equal opportunity where you can provide
equal chance for your neighbor to grow
and to prosper
you